es wird viel über den verfassungsschutz
im moment gesprochen wegen der fdp wird
inzwischen in vielen ländern von den
jeweiligen landesbehörden für
verfassungsschutz als verdachtsfall
beobachtet aber was heißt das eigentlich
was ist der unterschied zwischen einem
prüfer ein verdachtsfall einer gesichert
extremistische bewegung was darf der
verfassungsschutz was da war nicht und
warum haben parteien eigentlich so eine
angst davor auch nur als bloßer
verdachtsfall zu gelten
ich heiße nicole diekmann ich arbeite im
zdf hauptstadtstudio und ich hab mir das
mal genauer für euch angeguckt sachsen
anhalt sachsen brandenburg und thüringen
was haben die vier gemeinsam in 14
ländern steht die afg im verdacht gegen
unsere freiheitlich demokratische
grundordnung zu verstoßen und wird
deshalb vom verfassungsschutz beobachtet
zuletzt ist sachsen in den kreis der
verdächtigen gestoßen und das liegt
unter anderem an aussagen vom
bundestagsabgeordneten jens meier wie
diesen
sind das für leute die eigentlich nur
eins im sinn haben irgendwie sich zu
entschuldigen
der mann in ost minister was der frage
der moment hatte ich bin da was die
regeln hauschild in die politik gegangen
was ist denn das für ein paar so
aussagen wie schuldkult für das größte
verbrechen in der geschichte der
menschheit das wird quasi automatisch
verfassungsschützer innen auf den plan
weil der holocaust möglicherweise
relativiert wird gilt eine partei als
verdachtsfall dann hat der
verfassungsschutz sie in der regel
vorher eine zeitlang erstmal geprüft in
der phase ist sie also ein prüfer in
dieser phase dürfen die
verfassungsschützer innen nur quellen
benutzen die allen zugänglich sind also
auch euch oder mir das heißt man
analysiert reden man analysiere
zeitungsinterviews social media so was
erhärtet sich in dieser zeit durch diese
prüfung der verdacht dass diese partei
womöglich verfassungsfeindlich agiert
dann ist sie genau ein verdacht zwei und
ab dem moment darf man dann auch
nachrichtendienstliche mittel einsetzen
wie das so schön heißt das bedeutet die
verfassungsschützer innen dürfen
telefone anzapfen e mail konten hätten
also was wir genau müssen wir uns als
eigentlich vorstellen so glamourös und
so abenteuerlich und spektakulär wie in
james-bond-filmen ich habe mal den chef
des thüringischen verfassungsschutz-
stephan kramer gefragt was gehört in die
welt der filme öffentlich heißt dass ihr
nicht auch unkonventionell unterwegs
sind aber da bitte ich um verständnis
wenn ich ihr nicht alle karten auf den
tisch lege auch wenn man sie
möglicherweise an der einen oder anderen
stelle in manchen romanen auch nachlesen
kann
aber so ein bisschen geheimniskrämerei
gehört nicht nur für einen kramer
sondern auf den nachrichtendienst dazu
weil wir wollen ja nicht alle
möglichkeiten auf den tisch legen wie
wir unterwegs sind um informationen
zusammen in thüringen wo stephan kramer
ja eben verfassungsschutzchef ist dpa
afd schon beobachtet da geht sie schon
als verdachtsfall chef der thüringischen
afd ist jan hoet kennt ihr höcker war
lange zusammen mit seinen engen
vertrauten andreas kalbitz der führende
kopf des sogenannten flügels dem
sammelbecken der rechts
außen in der ohnehin rechten afd
der flügel nicht mal mehr nur ein paar
dach zwei sondern laut verfassungsschutz
längst gesichert rechtsextremistisch
genauso wie die beiden chefs beide
personen sind rechtsextremisten heute
teile ich ihnen mit dass wir den flügel
als erwiesen extremistische bestrebungen
eingestuft haben hacker darf man
übrigens ganz offiziell einen faschisten
nennen das hat ein gericht entschieden
kein wunder höcker hitler da kommen
selbst eigene parteifreunde
durcheinander ein paar korrekturen und
reförmchen werden nicht ausreichen aber
die deutsche unbedingtheit wird der
garant dafür sein dass wir die sache
gründlich und grundsätzlich anpacken
werden wenn einmal die wende zeit
gekommen ist dann machen wir deutschen
keine halben sachen dann werden die
schutthalden der moderne beseitigt ist
das aus meinem kampf oder von händel
da werde ich mich jetzt nicht festlegen
könnte von beiden sein wenn er für aus
mein kampf nichts sagen auch nicht von
energie ich habe weder das eine noch das
andere buch gelesen insoweit muss ich
passen
ein zweites beispiel zitat hocken die
sehnsucht der deutschen nach einer
geschichtlichen figuren welche einst die
wunden im volk wieder heilt die
zerrissenheit überwindet und die dinge
wieder in ordnung bringt ist tief in
unserer seele verankert ist das aus mein
kampf oder von einheit also die frage
werde ich ihnen nicht beantworten können
weil ich mein kampf nicht gelesen habe
und ob das von der lücke ist weiß ich
auch nicht - wie ist dann gefällt mir
nicht was hat es gesagt hat wenn es von
dem anderen herrn der auch mit h beginnt
ist dann gefällt mir das schon zweimal
nicht von der dakar die eigentlich gar
nichts zu sagen
nach der einstufung als gesicherte
rechtsextremistisch ging die sache
ziemlich schnell der flügel ist jetzt
aufgelöst zumindest offiziell und
andreas kalbitz wurde aus der afg
geschmissen bisher zumindest
clark noch da kein witz war bis zu
seinem rausschmiss chef der
brandenburgischen afd
und die geld exakt als verdachtsfall in
der brandenburger fdp ist der flügel
links der ganze vogel
sie wurde und wird faktisch von einem
parteilosen rechtsextremisten geführt
andreas kalbitz ist also nicht mehr in
der afg nicht mehr chef der afd
brandenburg und auch nicht mehr chef der
fdp fraktion im landtag von brandenburg
diesen job hat jetzt hans christoph behr
von ihm übernommen mit dem er sich
ziemlich gut versteht
die behörden kennen hans christoph
berndt auch schon ziemlich gut denn der
hat 2015 einen verein gegründet der
heißt zukunft heimat und gilt als
gesichert rechtsextremistisch dieser
mann führt jetzt also die fdp-fraktion
in brandenburg ich habe mal den
extremismusforscher matthias kennt nach
seiner einschätzung gefragt gerade in
brandenburg kann man sehen dass also
einzeln erst mal ein unterschied der
general programmatischen ausrichtung
machen der landesverband die ist so
richtig dem baby auch woher das sieht
man an wo er sitzen wir an stellte trägt
mit vorsitzenden an den ausrichtungen
also raider heißt jetzt twix sonst
ändert sich nix
schauen wir mal der vollständigkeit
halber auf den landesverband sachsen
anhalt wird auch vom verfassungsschutz
dort beobachtet als verdachtsfall
und da ist jemand stellvertretender
landeschef dieser partei der sachen sagt
wie diese
[Musik]
aber doch
also wir fassen noch mal zusammen vier
landesverbände der afg werden inzwischen
von den dortigen landesämtern für
verfassungsschutz beobachtet als
verdachts weiter fragt sich relativ
logisch natürlich auch das bundesamt für
verfassungsschutz
was ist eigentlich mit der bundes partei
wenn sich zum beispiel führende
funktionärinnen auf eine stufe stellen
mit andreas kalbitz ich kenne ein calvis
besser als sie nehme ich an
sehen sie und wir haben schon im landtag
zusammen gearbeitet
weder habe ich ihn je als scharfmacher
empfunden
noch kann ich in irgendeiner weise
feststellen dass ihr rechtsradikales
gedankengut vertritt ja natürlich ist
andreas kalbitz genau so bürgerlich oder
wenn sie sich feiern lassen beim besuch
von außerparlamentarischen einrichtungen
die auch schon als verdachtsfall geführt
werden er hat neue polit prominenz zu
gast die frau weigerte glücklich sind
weil es ein sehr sehr schöner arm zu
werden verspricht ich wahrscheinlich
wichtig und schön jetzt zu seinen dank
für die einladung
der unterschied zum bundestag dass wir
hier gefüllten reihen
wir alle sind seine fans haben deswegen
sind bundespolitik ist ja sozusagen mein
ausgleich zum bundestag
nun gilt aber in deutschland ja der
grundsatz in dubio pro reo also im
zweifel für den angeklagten
solange man nur ein paar dach zahl ist
ist man der name sagt es nur ein
verdacht erst wenn dieser bestätigt wird
geht man als gesichert extremistisch und
erst dann in einem großen ersten schritt
könnte eventuell ein verbotsverfahren
eingeleitet werden warum aber haben
trotzdem die parteien eine so große
angst davor als bloßer verdacht zwei zu
gelten
ja das ist in verschiedenen kontexten
schon länger zu beobachten dass allein
dies sofort der aufmerksamkeit des
verfassungsschutzes zum
mitgliederschwund wird mitgliederschwund
und der hoch möglicherweise da zu sein
das halten viele in parteien für keine
allzu gute werbung vor allem in einem
superwahljahr zum beispiel afg chef jörg
macht der hat lange mit den rechten
gekungelt war zum beispiel öfter zu gast
bei den berühmt-berüchtigten kyffhäuser
treffen das waren die jährlichen
zusammenkünfte des inzwischen ja
offiziell aufgelösten flügels jetzt
klingt wollten aber anders er versucht
vielleicht noch zu retten was zu retten
ist zum beispiel in einer rede auf dem
bundesparteitag der afg im winter 2020
in kalkar da klang er so die sage das
kann und darf so keinesfalls weiter
gehen entweder wir kriegen hier die
kurve und zwar sehr entschlossen und
sehr bald oder wer werden dass parteien
keine zukunft ganz ganz schwere see
geraten und gegebenenfalls scheitern
wer also gerne weiter revolution oder
politik kasperle spielen will kann kann
und sollte das dann woanders tun aber
bitte nicht in der alten auch solche
aussagen muss der verfassungsschutz
natürlich in seiner analyse in seinen
entscheidungen berücksichtigen und sehr
genau dokumentieren
darauf weisen verfassungsschützer innen
im gespräch übrigens auch immer wieder
hin dass ihre entscheidungen ja im
zweifel auch vor gericht bestand haben
müssen weil parteien politiker auch
dagegen klagen darauf legt man so viel
wert in den beraten weil man sich immer
wieder dem vorwurf ausgesetzt sieht
politisch instrumentalisiert zu werden
diesen vorwurf erhebt auch die afd
obwohl ausgerechnet andreas kolbe zum
beispiel vor einiger zeit noch ganz
anders klagt die einschätzung wäre was
recht stream ist auch nicht trifft immer
noch zum glück in deutschland der
verfassungsschutz das war allerdings
bevor andreas kalbitz selbst vom
verfassungsschutz als gesichert
rechtsextremistisch eingestuft wurde
so ich hoffe ich konnte euch heute ein
bisschen was erklären wie der
verfassungsschutz arbeitet warum er so
wichtig für uns alle ist weil er nämlich
unsere demokratie verteidigt und warum
parteien auch schon vor der einstufung
als bloßer verdachtsfall angst haben hat
euch gefallen dann lasst ein leichter
und falls ihr noch fragen hat oder auch
kritik schreibt sie unten in die
kommentare
ich verspreche ich versuche alle zu
beantworten
und falls es euch sehr gut gefallen hat
empfiehlt uns weiter und abonniert uns
doch wir kommen jetzt immer regelmäßig
für andere themen die ihr wichtig findet
dass wir sie hier untersuchen
hinterfragen und erklären auch dafür
sind die kommentare da bis zum nächsten
mal wir freuen uns auf euch